[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY PISHNY: All
right, hi, everyone.
Welcome.
My name is Mary Pishny.
I'm a product manager
on Data Studio.
RICCARDO MUTI: And
I'm Riccardo Muti.
I'm a product manager as well.
MARY PISHNY: We're
excited to be here today.
So we have a pretty
full session for you,
so we'll just go ahead
and jump right in.
First things first, let's
start with questions.
So we will have time at
the end for questions.
You've probably seen this slide
in some of your breakouts.
But if you're not aware,
there's a Dory link in the app.
We also will have live
questions as well.
So feel free to
make use of both.
We're excited to hear
your questions at the end.
OK, so we have about 40
minutes of content for you.
And the content's
really structured
around common problems
that many of you
have faced when
you're using BI Tools
and really trying to get
data out to your colleagues
so you all can make
better decisions.
So to start us off, we're
going to do a little warm up.
It's the end of day two on
this wonderful conference.
So I'm going to do a little
audience participation.
Just all you have to
do is raise your hand.
It's pretty minimal.
So I'm going to
ask you a question.
Raise your hand
if this resonates.
Let's see here.
So raise your hand if you
have started running a query,
it started taking a little bit
of time, so you got distracted.
You went to go check your
email and you never came back.
All right, personally,
it's definitely happened.
OK, another one for you.
Raise your hand if you
get asked to write a SQL
query for a colleague
on a regular basis.
I heard some laughter.
Resonates with us.
OK, last but not least, not
Data Studio, not Google Cloud
related, San Francisco related.
How many of you have visited
San Francisco in the summer
and frozen?
Yes, I'm a resident.
And I still get
caught off guard.
So as I said, we're
excited to be here today.
We have about the next
45 minutes with you all.
We'll spend the majority
of it on talking
about these common problems
and then actually going
through the real solutions
that you can start using today.
We have lots of demos
planned for you.
So I hope you guys are excited.
We'll spend a little bit
of time talking about some
of the new features.
And a lot of these
are interspersed
throughout our content
today, so you'll
be seeing a lot of stuff
that's brand new as of today.
And then, as I said, we'll
have time for Q&A at the end.
OK, so kind of set
the stage, many of you
have experienced a lot
of these challenges
that we're going
to talk through.
But in this case, we're going to
use a fictional character named
Ruth.
Ruth works at the FAA.
And she is somebody who
came to Next last year.
She watched the Data
Studio and BigQuery session
and got really
excited about what it
could do for her and her work.
So she started using it to
distribute data to her teams
and start analyzing
data on flight delays.
And we're going to use this
thread throughout of some
of these common challenges
that she's seen as she's
progressing in her career.
One thing that I
would call out is
that Ruth was a victim
of her own success.
She was able to start using Data
Studio and BigQuery to really
start solving some
tough problems.
And then the emails
started coming in.
Can you give me
access to this data?
Can you help me with this query?
So we're going to talk about
how we can scale and solve
some of those problems.
So with that, I'm going to
go ahead and turn it over
to Riccardo to kick
us off on analysis.
RICCARDO MUTI: Sure.
Thank you, Mary.
So as Mary mentioned, Ruth
became known as the SQL guru,
the person who if you
had a business question,
you could send a
question to her.
She'd know how to craft
the SQL query for you
and send you back your CSV
file, your spreadsheet,
so you can do your analysis.
But she quickly became
inundated with those requests.
So her goal is how
can she empower
her colleagues, many of whom are
not quite so technical as her,
not quite such a SQL
guru, to self serve,
to do some of their
own data analysis?
But some of the
challenges with that
are, number one, how do we
make data analysis easy enough
for those less technical users?
Some of them don't
know much SQL.
Some of them don't know any SQL.
So really making it easy
means making it visual,
making it interactive,
making it natural.
And then the other
thing that happens
is she'll send somebody a
report, and they'll say, well,
can you also add this
column and this column?
And I need these two
things added together.
We can't anticipate every
dimension and every metric
that all these different
users might need.
And they sometimes
invent their own metrics
derived on top of the data.
How can we make it possible
for them to enrich the data,
do a little bit of this
light data modeling,
and add their own dimensions
and metrics and calculations,
and make it as easy as them
doing that sort of thing
by writing a formula in a
spreadsheet for example?
And last but not least, how do
we make that whole experience
just wicked fast?
If you're clicking on a
column in a column chart,
or you're clicking on
a slice in a pie chart,
whereas when you're
running a SQL query,
if you get a result
over terabytes
of data in 10 seconds, 15
seconds, that's rather amazing.
But it's not good
enough in this scenario.
People are going to be clicking
through things, drilling,
filtering, slicing, dicing.
It needs to be two seconds,
one second, maybe sub second.
So how do we do that?
So enough talking about this.
I'm going to show you
how you can do it.
So we already talked
about how Ruth is really
the champion for
BigQuery within the FAA,
within her organization,
within her team.
She got all of this flight
data landed into BigQuery.
And from there, she
writes her SQL query.
She's super productive.
She gets her answers.
She exports the data.
She sends CSV files
to people and so on.
But if you wanted to go from
BigQuery to Data Studio, how
exactly do you do that?
Well, it can be
as simple as this.
I just go from a BigQuery
table and I go to export.
And I say explore
in Data Studio.
And it's going to create the
connection for you, set it
all up.
And in a moment here,
we'll see a live connection
to the BigQuery table and some
results that are coming back.
And when you do this, and
you actually save your work,
one of the artifacts
that gets created
is called a data source.
It's what Data Studio
calls a data source.
And it is the proxy for your
data, for your BigQuery table.
It's a secure connection to it.
It knows how to
authenticate to it.
You can give all of your fields
friendly human readable names.
You can add additional
calculated fields.
And now if you share this with
your users instead of the CSV
file or a spreadsheet,
they're one click away
from creating a
report on top of this
without worrying about
prepping the data,
or connecting to the data,
or just maybe visually
exploring the data.
And that's what I'm
going to focus on today.
You know Data Studio
as this great tool
to be able to design these
really beautiful reports.
But right now, I don't even
know what report I want.
I'm new to this data.
I want to familiarize
myself with it
I want to see what's in it, what
interesting metrics and trends.
What are some different ways
of visualizing the data?
And so I want just
a really productive
rapid visual
exploration experience.
And so that's Data
Studio Explorer.
It's a different
part of Data Studio
that many people
haven't played with yet.
But it's getting better
and better with every month
that we invest into it.
And I want to show you.
So one of the things
I might do first
is I might just have
a metadata question,
like, how large
is this data set?
How large is this table?
This scorecard will aggregate
a metric into a single number.
And so it automatically
created a record count metric
for me, which is
the number of rows.
And so this is going to
aggregate the total number
of rows in the table.
And just like that,
I can see I have
116 million rows worth of
data in this BigQuery table.
So all of the
performance that you're
going to see as I'm clicking
around, drilling, slicing,
filtering is doing live
queries over 116 million rows
worth of data.
And it's still going to be fast.
So each row represents a flight.
So this is 116 million flights
over the last almost 20 years
or so worth of data.
Another analytic
technique that I will use
is looking at the same
data in different ways
through different types
of visualizations,
different types of charts,
or in this case, maybe a map.
What I want to do
is I want to look
at which states have
the most flights
departing from them,
which states have the most
departures.
And just like that, it live
queried 116 million rows,
geocoded the states
based on their name
and plotted them on a map.
And they're colored
in color intensity
by how many departures
are from those states.
So the most is California,
followed closely by Texas.
That's at the state level.
What if I wanted to
look at the city level?
What are the cities
with the most
departures in the
United States for
domestic commercial flights?
Well, another
analytic technique is
to look at data different
ways simultaneously.
So I'm not limited to one chart.
I can add another
chart beside this.
And maybe here, I want to
go add the origin city.
Before I drag that
in, what do you
think the city is
in the United States
with the most departures
for domestic flights?
Anyone want to venture a guess?
LA.
Anyone else?
JFK.
OK, those are good guesses.
I drag this in.
Drum roll.
It's Chicago.
There you go.
And so I'll just make
this a little bit bigger
so we can easily read it.
Top three Chicago,
Atlanta, Dallas.
Does anyone know why
those cities are special?
Connections.
They are the largest hub of the
three largest airlines, United,
Delta, and American
Airlines respectively.
Cool.
So those are the top cities
with departures in the US.
MARY PISHNY: All
right, Riccardo,
we're in the Bay Area.
Can we look at destinations
coming into San Francisco?
RICCARDO MUTI: Oh, so we want
to look at the destination
is San Francisco.
MARY PISHNY: Yes.
RICCARDO MUTI: And
so, OK, so what
are the cities with the
most departures not anywhere
but to San Francisco
specifically?
So it sounds like we want
to filter to San Francisco.
And so look how easy that is.
I can just go up to
my filter shelf here.
I've got a field
called destination.
Destination, city
name, I'll pick that.
I can open this up.
And just like that,
I've got a filter.
I can scroll down and
find San Francisco.
But this is Google,
so let's Google it.
So I'm going to
do San Francisco.
If I can spell San Francisco.
OK.
And now I don't need to
uncheck everything else.
I can just have this
handy button here that
says I only want San Francisco.
And just like that-- no
SQL, no where clause.
And sub second response, I've
filtered 116 million rows.
The city with the most
departures to San Francisco
is no longer Chicago.
It's LA.
So a lot of people commuting
from LA to San Francisco.
These charts aren't just charts.
They're not just
pretty pictures.
They are automatically
interactive.
And we're making them more and
more interactive every month.
So one of the things that
we're launching just today
is the ability to quickly
sort any chart that
supports sorting to be able to
sort it right from the chart.
I don't have to go into
the configuration for it.
I could just say, well, if these
are the cities with the most
departures to San
Francisco, what
are the cities with the fewest
departures to San Francisco
over the last 20 years?
Has anyone ever flown
from Lewiston, Idaho
to San Francisco?
OK, over the last
20 years, there
was a grand total of one flight.
So if you were on that flight,
it was literally a once
in a lifetime experience.
Also interesting
that's catching my eye
here is there were eight flights
from San Jose to San Francisco.
If you don't know your
Bay Area geography,
that is like 38 miles from here.
I took an Uber.
Mary does this commute
several times a week.
I don't know if you noticed
that once every couple of years
or so, there's a
flight home available.
MARY PISHNY: I'm going
to start looking.
RICCARDO MUTI: So yeah,
so these are the insights
that we can reveal only by
interacting with the data
and just exploring.
Not only are these
charts interactive,
but they are automatically
linked to each other.
I didn't do any special
configuration here.
But if I want to
filter by California,
I don't have to keep defining
these filters in the filter
shelf.
I'm already plotting
something by state.
So I could just
click on California
to cross filter cities with the
most departures in California,
in Texas, in Florida.
And look at the speed that
I'm getting from that.
How am I getting that speed?
So actually, it's courtesy
of the BigQuery BI Engine.
There was a session on
this just before this one.
It was shown in the
keynote as well.
This is launching in beta today.
So definitely go back
and watch those videos
and check this out and
learn more about it.
All you really need to know
about it is this column
store in memory engine, it just
makes everything super fast.
OK?
So this is operating on
top of BigQuery BI Engine.
So you might have
recognized that technique
that I did there as
sort of a drill down,
like I'm drilling down from
state to city and drilling
into California and Texas
and Florida and so on.
It's good if I want these
multifaceted views, a map
and a chart.
But what if I don't want to
consume the space for that?
I really just need the
one with the ability
to navigate between those
two levels of detail, state
and city.
So you can now do that.
I'm going to take
origin state name
and drag it into this
chart into the hierarchy.
And now, what is this button?
I can drill up
from city to state.
See the top states.
I can drill back
down to top cities.
This is drill down.
And it's available today
in Data Studio for most
of the basic chart types.
MARY PISHNY: Awesome.
RICCARDO MUTI: Yeah.
You can applaud that.
Sure.
Why not?
OK, not only can I
drill down, but I
can still do that filtered
drill down that I did before.
So I can look at,
for example, what are
the top cities in California?
Just select
California, drill down,
and those are the top
cities in California.
Pretty cool, huh?
So what if I wanted to drill
down into multiple things?
Like what if I
wanted to drill down
into only the Northwest, the
Pacific Northwest, Oregon
and Washington?
This can be actually
tricky to do
in some tools, where you're
limited to drill down
into a single item at a time.
Here, I can do multi select.
You'll see the Pacific
Northwest selected in the map.
And I can drill
down and see these
are the cities with the most
departures in the Pacific
Northwest.
OK, we haven't done any
time series analysis yet.
So maybe that would
be a good point
to introduce that, so look
at some trends over time.
So maybe let me
multi select these.
And I'm just going to
make a little bit of room
so that I can do some
light rearrangement
and make some space for me to
introduce another chart here.
So you can do some light
layout in Explorer.
Let's add a time series chart.
And again, my automatic
record count metric
is just going to show
me the number of flights
over this almost
20-year time period.
And one of the things
we see is that there are
some months with missing data.
So no data is without
its data quality issues.
There's also a lot of
noise because there's
seasonal fluctuation.
I'm really just interested
in the long term trend.
Here, I'm going to drill up.
I didn't even configure
a hierarchy in this case.
It just knows that this
is a date time data type.
And so it added year,
month, and day for me.
I can just drill up
without any configuration.
That's month.
And that's year.
Automatic drill down.
Now, you'll notice that
it plummets in 2018,
and that doesn't seem
to make sense to me.
Because if I drill
back down to month,
I don't see it plummeting
at the end of 2018.
The thing is, what's
going on here?
It looks like the data only
goes up until July, August 2018.
So I don't have
full data for 2018.
Look how easy this is
to filter this out.
I only want to look
at this by year.
And I want to drag year up here.
And I'm going to say, OK,
2018 has partial data.
So let me just filter that out.
I'm doing the opposite
of what I did before.
I don't want only 2018.
I want everything but 2018.
I'll click Apply.
And I've filtered out that
year with partial data
just like that.
So that's the number
of flights that's
been increasing over the years.
It would be interesting to
see what other metrics I
have in here.
So let's see.
I'll go to my metric picture.
And I think we've got some
data on flight delays.
So I've got, yeah,
like departure delay.
Do you think that the average
departure delay has gone down
or up over the last few years?
How many people
think it's gone down?
That's pretty sad.
How many people
think it's gone up?
OK, the vast majority of you.
OK, so let's drag
departure delay.
And departure delays
have been going up
for at least the
last 17 years or so.
They've been getting
gradually worse
from about 6 minutes to 17,
18 minutes in the last year
or couple years ago.
So is that trend true
everywhere, though?
And again, you'll see the
power of this cross filtering.
I can explore my data
with minimal to little
to no configuration.
I noticed Seattle in here.
I live in Seattle.
And so I do the jet commute
from Seattle to-- oh,
some Seattle people, OK,
or person, one person, OK.
So I can look at, does
this trend hold true?
Has the delays been increasing
for Seattle to San Francisco?
I just filter that.
And it hasn't, thankfully.
So thankfully for me,
I guess that flight
has been holding steady.
What other metrics
do I have in here?
So I've got departure delay.
I can also add arrival delay.
So look at arrival
delay alongside that.
And that actually has been
steady, or if anything,
decreasing as well.
Other metrics, I
think I have a metric
in here about the actual
elapsed flight time.
Maybe that's also
what I care about.
How long is it going
to take me to fly
from Seattle to San Francisco?
I mean, this I wouldn't
think would change very much,
except it has a lot.
What's interesting
is this has gone up
a lot between 2004 and 2007, and
then again really skyrocketing
the last couple of years.
If the flight's not
delayed, then why
would the actual time of
the flight be taking longer?
Well, I mean, I
guess it's possible
that they've just scheduled
the flight to take longer.
So I actually have the scheduled
elapsed time of the flight.
And sure enough,
those are correlated.
So they've actually
just been scheduling
my flight from Seattle
to San Francisco
to take longer and longer.
Why would they schedule
a flight to take longer?
Busy airports.
OK, what could that impact?
MARY PISHNY: Fuel.
RICCARDO MUTI: Fuel,
slower to fuel.
MARY PISHNY: Yeah.
RICCARDO MUTI: I don't know.
What do you think?
MARY PISHNY: Can you take
a look at taxi times,
so taxiing in and taxiing out?
See if there's anything
going on there?
RICCARDO MUTI: Yes.
So maybe the time is spent on
the ground and not in the air.
So I can search for taxi.
The problem is, as you
just pointed out, yeah,
I guess there's taxi out
and there's taxi back in.
I'm actually interested
in the sum of those.
I don't have that.
But I can easily create
that by just creating
a calculated field and saying,
I want taxi out plus taxi in.
And of course, I can do other
calculations as well, but just
on the fly, taxi
in, click Apply.
Does that trend look familiar?
A big increase
from 2004 to 2007,
and again, last couple of years.
Taxi time has gone from 19
minutes to almost half an hour.
So is that trend holding
across other airports
in the United States?
If I look at Chicago, it was
getting better for a long while
until the last five years or so
that it's been getting worse.
In New York, it's kind of always
been bad, over half an hour.
But it looks like
in 2007 and 2008,
it was close to 45 minutes
on the ground in a plane.
So these are just
some of the insights
that you can get by
visually exploring
your data in this way.
I showed off new features
of Data Studio as well as,
of course, the
BigQuery BI Engine
that was giving us
the snappy response
throughout the whole thing.
So I've analyzed my data.
What next?
I'm going to hand it over to
Mary to take the next steps.
MARY PISHNY: Awesome.
Thanks, Riccardo.
All right, so Riccardo
went through some
of the analysis workflow.
But we know that there is a next
stage of making sure that this
is consumable for users.
So I'm going to hop
back here real quick.
So jumping back to
our heroine Ruth,
she has four problems she wants
to solve now that she's gone
through this analysis stage.
One is that she
needs to make sure
that interactive experience
continues on for viewers,
so they can continue to
interact with the data
once she shares
it out with them.
Two is she wants
it to be tailored
for the particular
audiences, whether that's
leadership or practitioners
on the ground.
And then lastly, she needs to
be able to actually distribute
these reports in a really
efficient and effective manner.
So those are the problems
I want us to solve.
Let's go see how to do that.
OK, so we were--
let me find the right tab.
Wrong tab.
Here we go.
OK, so Riccardo walked
us through this analysis,
this deep dive on San Francisco.
I'm going to actually
take what he has here.
And I have a report
going on that I've
been spending some
time on looking
at some of these same trends.
And I'm going to
actually go over here.
What we have is that
report that I created.
So looking at flights by
carrier, cancellations,
arrival, and departure delays.
And then I also have a
San Francisco deep dive.
And I'm ready to drop
those charts that we just
created into our report.
So all I did was
save that analysis.
I copied those charts.
And then I brought
it in here, so I
can continue to work with this
data and start sharing it out.
So I'm going to apply some
light styling changes.
OK, actually looks pretty good.
Let me drop this
down a little bit.
OK, so the first thing
I want to solve here
is that I could share this
out with my viewers as is.
Sure.
But I want them to still be
able to interact with this data.
So I can add controls
to the page that make
that really easy for our users.
So one is origin city name.
So they can quickly
select what origin
of the flights taking off from.
And I'm also going
to add one so they
can filter by carrier name.
So let me-- carrier name.
Perfect.
So what that looks like
here, I can come in
and say, show me all
the United flights.
Do a quick select, and that's
going to update on the fly.
RICCARDO MUTI: Cool.
MARY PISHNY: Yeah.
RICCARDO MUTI: So one of the
things that I often find,
or that we often see as well is
that you share this report out
with people, and
then they come back
with questions like,
what does this mean?
Am I interpreting
this correctly?
How do I use this report?
So do you have any tips
for how to solve that?
MARY PISHNY: Yes.
That's a common
problem or a challenge
that we hear is, how
do I educate users when
they're looking at this data?
So what I'm going
to do in this case
is we have something
called URL embed
that makes it easy to embed
other content directly
into your report.
So in this case, we
have flight data.
And it's looking at San
Francisco in particular.
So I actually found
a YouTube video.
And it gives an overview of
the San Francisco airport
annual report.
And so I'm actually going
to include this directly
into my report.
And so users, as they're
interacting with the data,
can come in and learn
a little bit more
about San Francisco
operations, give them
some context for as they're
consuming this data.
And then lastly,
it's pretty common
that as you're going
through some analysis,
you're taking notes.
You're finding some call
outs about the schema.
I've put those all in just a
quick doc with some information
about the data set, some
information about the schema
itself, some delay codes.
And I'm going to take
that same approach here.
And instead of having to
send this over in an email,
I'm going to actually just embed
that directly into the report.
So I can now interact
with both the video--
I won't play it for us;
it's a little dated--
and this document that
has some more context
on my analysis all right here.
So pretty powerful.
So now that I have this
interactive viewing experience,
I've tailored it so they can
consume the data right away.
And now I'm ready to actually
start distributing that data.
So we have a couple different
options based on the audience.
Number one is I can come in here
and just download this report.
We know that a lot of people
still operate in PDF mode,
so we can quickly get a
PDF to download with them.
I can also just share the
link with them directly,
so they can quickly go
and consume this online.
RICCARDO MUTI: The
download PDF feature's
definitely really useful.
I think one thing
we find often is
people are asking me to
email them the updated
report every week.
So is there a way that we
can just automate that?
MARY PISHNY: You
set me up, Riccardo.
This is perfect.
So we have email
delivery, which delivers
the report in your inbox.
It's a really rich experience.
I actually want to give you
guys all a little homework
and go try this out today.
It puts the report
directly into your inbox.
So in a lot of cases, you can
consume that data right there.
Sometimes, you might
want to click through
to learn a little bit more.
It's also available in PDF.
So you can make sure that
if you want your team
to be seeing this every
Monday or every day
you're looking at this
data, you can make sure
that this is in front of them
in a place where we spend
a lot of our time these days.
So we've gone
through the analysis
with Riccardo, as well as
actually taking that report,
making it into something
that's consumable, but still
interactive and
distributing it out.
We're going to jump
back to Ruth's story.
And with that, we're
to bring Minhaz up
on the stage, who's going to
show us what's next for Ruth.
All right.
MINHAZ KAZI: All
right, thank you, Mary.
Hi.
I'm Minhaz Kazi.
I'm one of the developer
advocates for Data Studio.
And we're going to take you
through the rest of Ruth's
story.
So Ruth has been doing
very well at her job.
She has set up this whole
entire data pipeline
based on BigQuery BI Engine.
She has set up all
the dashboards, set up
the PDF exports.
People are getting reports.
People are running analyses.
Everything has been going
really well for Ruth
until something really
terrible happens.
Ruth gets promoted
to be a manager.
So now Ruth has a
different set of problems.
Because she had
solved all that issue
where people were
emailing her about,
can you write this SQL for me?
Or can you debug
this SQL code for me?
But it went from being that
to people setting up meetings
with her and people setting
up emails saying that, hey,
my dashboard is broken.
Can you fix it?
My dashboard is
running very slow.
Can you fix that one?
I've been getting
this code error issue.
What is this about?
So she starts getting
all of these complaints.
And she starts
taking note of them,
and she wants to solve
this with her team.
So the major problem she
runs across is again,
can we make all the
dashboards fast?
Now, in Ruth's department,
they were using the BI Engine
to make things faster.
However, at this point,
all the other departments
in her organization are not
using the same BI Engine
approach.
For example, marketing
has been pulling in data
from Google
Analytics, Google Ads.
Finals has been putting
their data in CSV files
and in Sheets.
HR has set up their own My
SQL instance in the basement
in a server.
So all of those reports
need to be faster.
So what is the solution
that Ruth came up with?
Well, you obviously can migrate
to the BigQuery BI Engine.
You can take your data,
put it in BI Engine,
and pull the reports from there.
And if you think about the
spectrum where you have,
I want really fast
dashboards, and I want my data
to be updated regularly,
BI Engine actually
takes care of both of these.
However, if that's
not an option for you,
then you can go the
extract data way,
which will let you make
really fast dashboards.
So let's take a look
at how that works.
Over here, I have
a dashboard that
is pulling in live Twitter
data from the Twitter
API for the Google
Data Studio hashtag.
And this is a
Twitter data source.
If I view this, and
then I refresh it,
you'll see that it
takes some time.
It will reach into
the connector.
It will pull the API.
It will format the data.
So it takes some time to update
and refresh the dashboard.
If we want to make this
faster, what we could do
is go back in, select
the data source,
and use the extract
feature on it.
And to use the extract
feature, what we will do
is select extract data
as a new connector.
And so this is a new
connector, extract data.
Over on the left side, I will
have all the data sources
that I've created previously.
So I'll use the
Twitter data source.
I'll add that to the report.
I'll pick the fields
that are relevant for me.
So pick screen name, Twitter
text, date, retweet count.
And I'll pull back the
date as a date range.
As I click this Save and Extract
button, what Data Studio does
is reaches into the connector,
pulls in all the data,
and saves it on GCS
as a small bucket,
where all this data
is materialized
as a static source.
So I'll add this
back to the report.
And as I look at
the report, I see
there's this new untitled
data source that the one
that I just treated as a
materialized data source.
And if I view this,
and I click on Refresh,
you can see it's very fast.
So you can take
this data source,
and then you can create
new charts, tables with it,
and it'll remain very fast.
So that is one option.
The limitations of extract
data is that the data set
is limited to 100 megabytes.
And we're working
on a feature which
will let you automatically
schedule updates
through the extract data.
So you can set up scheduling.
And the data extract
would automatically
get updated at a
certain interval.
But what if you want to work on
the other end of the spectrum
where you want really
fresh data for your users?
As a dashboard owner, you can
always refresh the dashboard.
But if you want the dashboard
to be updated for your users
as well, then you need
a different approach.
And then Ruth's
solution was basically
to use the new feature
of data freshness.
This is available both
for BigQuery and Sheets,
where you can go into the
options for a data source
and set the interval by
which the data source should
be updated.
For Sheets, it'll be between
15 minutes to 12 hours.
And for BigQuery, it'll be
between one hour to 12 hours.
So this was Ruth's
first week as a manager.
The first week goes by.
She goes home,
spends the weekend.
She comes back on
Monday, opens her email,
and this is the first
email she choose.
It's an email from the
compliance department.
All of these reports you are
making and sharing with people,
what are you doing
about data governance?
Are you making
sure that everyone
is viewing exactly the data
that they have access to?
We know that we
have a lot of data
that can be shared
across organizations,
across the entire
organization, but there
are other data sets
that can be shared only
for specific people.
So people shouldn't be
viewing all the reports.
They should be able to view only
the stuff that they have access
to.
For this, she already
had an existing solution,
which was enforcing
viewer's credentials.
For each data source
in Data Studio,
you can go into
the data set option
and set the data
source access level
to either owners or viewers.
Owners lets you
view the data source
based on whoever created
the dashboard or the report.
But viewers ensures that if
you're viewing the report,
your credentials would get
passed into the data source.
And if you don't have
access to the data source,
you cannot view the data.
For example, let's say there
is a worksheet with all the HR
information about employees.
HR department has access to
it, but the sales department
does not.
So if you create a dashboard
from that data source
and then shared that
with other people,
the HR employees will
see what they're supposed
to see on the left side.
But if someone has access to
the dashboard who is not an HR
employee, not within
that organization,
they'll still be able
to open the dashboard,
but they'll just see that you
don't have access to this data
because that sheet was
not shared with you.
So this is done at a complete
entire data set level.
MARY PISHNY: Hey, Minhaz.
Can you talk us
through what we can
do if we need the security to
be administered on a row basis?
MINHAZ KAZI: That
is a good question.
Because what we're showing
right now is at an entire data
set basis.
But oftentimes,
organizations would
require role level access.
For example, in Ruth's team,
there are two analysts.
One of the analysts
works on the West Coast.
They focus mostly on
California and Oregon.
And another analyst focuses
on the DC metro area, the DC,
Virginia, and Maryland.
So the data she
has on flights, she
would like to
separate out this data
so that people can only see
what they have access to.
And to do that, they will
want to implement role level
security.
Ruth was trying to find ways.
What can she do?
So there was this
analyst in her team
who used to work as a
developer a long time ago.
They have some familiarity
with JavaScript,
but they're not a
full blown developer.
They're not a coder.
So they looked into the Data
Studio's developer website,
and they realized that
they can get this done
using community connectors.
They can implement a
community connector
and enforce viewer's
credentials with it.
The way it would work
is basically over here,
let's say, we have a report.
This is the report view for
the analyst who is viewing
the data for West Coast.
So they can only see
California and Oregon data.
And here are all the cities
for California and Oregon.
I'll take the exact same
report, copy the URL,
and I'll open it up for
the other analyst who has
access to the East Coast data.
So I'll paste in the
exact same report URL.
I won't change anything else.
And as I access this
report, you will
see that this person will
not see the West Coast data.
They'll see only
the East Coast data.
So you have Virginia
and Maryland.
So these are the exact
two same reports.
But over here, based on who
is accessing the report,
you're filtering the data
for the same data source.
It's the same table.
Only the rows are
getting filtered based
on who is viewing the report.
And to do that, all they have to
do, all the analysts have to do
is go into the Data Studio's
developer's website, figure out
how this community
connector works.
We have made it much easier.
Previously, you'd have to use
the BigQuery connector using
the REST API.
But we've introduced
a new feature
called advanced services that
lets you pass configuration
directly from Data
Studio into BigQuery.
So if you're
writing a connector,
the only thing you need to
pass is just the configuration
that I want data
from this table.
This is how you
should filter it.
And these are the
access token, which
makes the code very small.
The connector that I showed you,
the dashboard, the connector
code for that is this.
This is it.
This is only like probably
100 lines of code.
And most of it is just
configuration data.
There is no business
logic involved.
So anyone with minimal level
of understanding of JavaScript
should be able to implement
this in a very short time.
So that gets implemented.
A lot of people in
Ruth's organization
are now using Data Studio.
They are creating reports.
A new problem comes up.
It takes a long time for
people to get ramped up.
If they have never used
Data Studio before,
if they have never used BigQuery
before, once they start,
it takes them some
time to learn it.
So to go from just data
to a completed dashboard,
it takes maybe days or hours.
So a director comes by
Ruth's desk and asks, hey,
can we make this whole
approach much faster?
Can we maybe
implement templates so
that a new user can come
in, start with a template,
and they can get started
just like that, pretty fast?
And since a lot of users
will be doing this,
we also need to keep
this under cost.
We have to have cost control and
make sure the performance does
not get bogged down, even though
a lot of people are using it.
So Ruth remembers that last
year at the Next video,
she saw a similar solution,
which was the Chrome UX report.
It was a connector
created with Data Studio.
This is what the
connector looks like.
It's you basically go
in, this connector has
about more than a
terabyte of data,
about 5 million different URLs.
You just put in a URL.
And this is exactly the workflow
a normal user would complete.
They go to this URL.
They put in their
configuration information.
I'll just type in Google.com.
Click Connect.
And this pulls in the data
from BigQuery, configures it.
And then as I click
Create Report,
this lands me into a templated
report with my configured data.
So a regular user that had
previously no experience
with BigQuery or Data
Studio whatsoever
can go from just nothing to
their configured template
that they can edit and share
with other people in just four
clicks.
This is something we already
showed you last year.
But we have made more
improvements from this.
So this is a report
for Google.com.
If we want to change
the configuration,
if you want to see this for
a different website, what
we would have to do is
go back to the connector,
put in a new configuration,
go through the flow again,
and that would create
us a new report.
So you would get new reports for
every URL, for every website.
We tried to make this
simpler, so what we did
was a scalable report.
This is the exact same report.
But when you enable
the URL parameters,
you can just go in and
change the configuration
through the URL.
So this is showing
data for Wikipedia.
I can just go in, in
the URL parameters,
I just change this
for Stack Overflow.
It's still the same
report, but it will now
change the configuration,
call the connector again,
fetch the new data,
cache the new data,
and show you the
information for Stack
Overflow in the same dashboard.
So the viewer's credentials
paired with this URL parameter
lets you do massive
scalable reporting.
You can just create one
report and roll it out
to thousands of users.
They will only see
the information
that they have access to.
You can also take a
report and then pass
configurations in the URL.
And the user will end
up seeing different data
based on what configuration
you are passing.
So this is the architecture
of the connector
that we showed you last year.
So that gets solved.
People are now using all of
their internal data in the FAA.
They're creating analyses.
They're creating dashboards.
An analyst in Ruth's
team comes up and says,
I found something externally.
There is an external
data set that we
think would be really helpful.
It is not within
our organization.
It is not on BigQuery.
It is not in our database.
But we'd like to bring that in
and use that with Data Studio.
And this data set was on Kaggle.
So how could we bring in
Kaggle data into Data Studio?
There was a solution
available because we
launched the integration
between Kaggle and Data Studio.
Let's see an example for that.
Maybe I'll go onto
the Kaggle website.
This is a flight data
set on Kaggle website.
And the good thing is if you
log onto the Kaggle website
and navigate to any
Kaggle data set,
you'll have a little button
here that says open in,
and you can click Data Studio.
You can pick which
file you want.
And that will take you
from the Kaggle interface
into Data Studio
with the connector
configuration selected.
And it'll pull in
live data from Kaggle
and let you do that all the
analysis in Data Studio.
You can also take this data and
blend it with your own data.
Now, they brought in
the external data.
They merge it.
Everything has been going well.
Ruth gets more responsibilities.
The supply chain
analytics team has
been merged into Ruth's team.
They have been doing
a really great job.
But in the supply chain, they
have this prevalent practice
of using sankey chart for
a lot of their analysis.
And that's a chart type
that is not natively
available in Data Studio.
So this is a new problem
that Ruth has to solve.
I have to make this chart
type available in Data Studio
because my team needs to use it.
So how could they do that?
There is a new
feature available.
It is under developer
preview, which
is the community visualization.
And here's an example
of a sankey chart
available in Data Studio.
What you can do is create your
own chart using JavaScript.
You can use any popular
library that you want.
You can use D3 or
some other library,
create the chart, user
API, import that chart
into Data Studio,
and then that chart
will get rendered
in Data Studio.
And it'll work with your
existing data pipeline that
is available in Data Studio.
It will work with all
the filters, other chart
types, cross filtering.
Everything will work
out of the box as it is.
There is a nice gallery of
community visualizations
available.
This is made by one
of our partners.
Click inside.
This is showing small
multiples, which is interactive.
We have scatter chart, which
is another interactive scatter
chart where you
can do filtering.
You can exclude this one.
You can add this back.
If you want more
information about how
to use community connectors, you
can go into our developer site
and check out the
instructions there.
Now community
visualizations are not
limited to only the
stuff we have here.
You can build your own chart,
for example, the one we built
for the community vis launch.
This is a chart that shows
the release notes of Data
Studio over the last few years.
For example, in 2018, these
are all the releases we had.
And as we hover
over things, you can
see that we launched
this feature in July,
where Data Studio become a
part of the Google Marketing
platform.
So if you have a
idea for a chart,
if you know JavaScript or
have access to a resource that
can build JavaScript charts,
you can bring in your own chart
and render that in Data Studio.
Now this chart
shows what we have
done over the last few years.
But to show you what we're going
to do over the next few years,
here's Riccardo.
RICCARDO MUTI: All
right, thanks Minhaz.
So I'll wrap us
up really quickly.
[APPLAUSE]
We want to get to your
questions as well for sure.
But I just want to
talk a little bit
about how we think
about the investments
that we're making
in Data Studio.
Our goal really is to help
you make better decisions
by helping you along
this entire workflow
from how you connect
to your data,
how you make it fast with
things like BigQuery BI Engine,
how you get it into the right
form, how you analyze it using
the visual tools that we have
like filtering and sorting
and drill down.
Today, I showed
drill down in charts.
Now we're starting to extend
that to pivot tables as well.
And we want to work on other
types of interactivity that
add analytic value as well.
On the reporting front,
conditional formatting
is something that we've
heard from a lot of people.
And Mary and team are hard
at work on that feature.
Distribution, we showed
scheduled email today.
We're interested in other
types of distribution as well.
And so we have investments
in each one of these areas.
There's also cross
cutting investments.
We're always investing in
our developer platform.
We showed community
visualizations,
community connectors.
We're really just getting
started with those.
And so we envision a
world where there's
lots and lots of
community visualizations
that you can go and choose
from and build upon as well.
And one of the areas where
we've heard a lot of feedback
is Data Studio started as this
very, very easy to use tool.
It looks a lot like Google
Docs and Google Slides.
And the files get saved
in your Google Drive.
But what happens when
somebody leaves the company?
What happens when you want
shared ownership of things?
What if you are a
Google Cloud customer,
and you manage everything
in GCP projects?
Wouldn't it be nice if you
could store your reports
and your data models
in GCP projects?
What if you have Google
Cloud Identity set up
and you have policies
there set up?
What if you could hook
into those things?
So one of the things we're
looking at and working on is,
how can we bring more enterprise
administration capabilities
built on Google Cloud
Platform to Data Studio?
So stay tuned for that.
Just recapping some of the
things that we showed today,
these are all available today.
They've either been
launched very recently,
or they have launched
literally this morning.
Drill down is one of them.
Scheduled email delivery, we
launched earlier this year.
Sorting launched today as well.
The BigQuery BI Engine,
of course, launched today.
If you want to stay
on top of this stuff,
support.Google.com/datastudio.
We publish release
notes every week or so.
So stay tuned for all
the latest announcements.
[MUSIC PLAYING]